police in George are investigating
allegations that Buffalo Bills star
LeSean McCoy was behind a violent attack
on his former girlfriend a photo
provided by her lawyer yesterday shows
her apparent injuries
mark Strassmann is in Alpharetta Georgia
outside Atlanta near the home where the
alleged assault took place mark good
morning good morning when Sean McCoy's
ex-girlfriend lives in the suburban home
he owns it and court records show he's
been trying to evict her for more than a
year now the issue is whether they're
unpleasant breakup has turned violent
including a home invasion and a pistol
whipping we do have speedy and reference
to police say the attack around 3:00
a.m. Tuesday was not random
hours later photos of delecia cordons
bloody face appeared online she is the
ex-girlfriend of Buffalo Bills all-pro
running back LeSean McCoy in a statement
Gordon's attorney said a male assailant
who entered the home while Corden was
sleeping demanded specific items of
jewelry McCoy had given her and hit MS
Gordon in the face with a firearm
multiple times while she didn't accuse
McCoy of ordering the attack Gordon's
attorney said he would often suggest to
ms Gordon that she could be robbed
because the jewelry was expensive Jay
Busbee covers the NFL for Yahoo Sports
there's a very clear implication that
mr. McCoy is either involved in this
attack or at the very least didn't seem
to show a whole lot of interest in miss
Gordon's health after the attack court
filings show McCoy has tried to kick
Corden out of the house twice in the
last year saying she has been living
rent-free for the past five months even
though they were no longer in a
relationship
McCoy is the latest NFL star to be
accused of domestic violence over the
last four years the league has been
criticized for seemingly turning the
other way this is yet another chance for
the league to demonstrate that it has a
strong domestic violence policy and not
only that for the league to demonstrate
that it takes this seriously
Gordon's lawyer says it's possible the
home security system live-streamed the
attack McCoy who's on his way back to
Atlanta today says that these
allegations are totally baseless and
offensive Alex mark thanks